today on how they do it JavaScript today
we'll look at the computer science
behind it so by the end of this video
you should understand what a high-level
single-threaded garbage-collected
interpreted or just-in-time compiled
prototype-based multi-paradigm dynamic
language with a non-blocking event loop
concurrency model really means if you're
new you're like and subscribe because
this is part 2 of the full javascript
course on fire ship i/o last week we
learn that javascript is a programming
language based on the ECMO 262 spec but
in order to really understand how it
works in a computer system we need to go
to the very bottom of the stack and by
that I mean the bare metal CPU and
memory on a machine this is a riddle
computer on hearing Ishida the tips that
make the computer work when you run a
JavaScript program whether that be a web
application in the browser or something
server side with nodejs it needs to
allocate memory on your RAM to store
things for the runtime and for variables
and objects that you reference in your
code then it also needs a thread from
your CPU to actually execute the
instructions in your code but here's the
thing as a JavaScript developer you
never really have to think about this
stuff because it's a high-level
programming language but what do we
really mean when we say high-level we're
talking about the degree of abstraction
or simplification that the language
provides over the computer's hardware
the lowest level language is machine
code
it's a numeric language that can be
executed directly by the CPU but it
would be extremely difficult to build a
website with it because you would have
to memorize a number for every single
instruction that you want to run if we
go up one level to assembly we get some
syntactic sugar but each assembly
language is specific to a particular CPU
or operating system so we can move up
another level to the C language which
provides a modern syntax and the ability
to write cross-platform programs but the
developers still has to be concerned
with low-level issues like memory
allocation if we go one more step higher
we reach the level of languages like
JavaScript and Python that use
abstractions like garbage collectors and
dynamic typing to simplify the way
developers write their applications so
now that we're at this high level let's
go ahead and unpack a few of the key
terms related to JavaScript now there
are two fundamental ways that we can
translate the code written in a
programming language to something that
the CPU can actually execute one of them
is called an interpreter and the other
is called a compiler javascript is an
interpreted language which means that it
needs to have an
in the environment to read the actual
source code and executed we can
demonstrate this by simply going into
the browser and running some JavaScript
code from the console now notice how the
interpreter works he stays with you all
the time
and he translates each of your
instructions immediately one by one now
this differs from a compiled language
like Java or C which will statically
analyze all of your code in advance and
then compile it down to a binary that
you can actually run on the machine he
takes you a complete list of
instructions and without further ado
translates the whole lot he then hands
them back to you and goes away leaving
you all on your own javascript was never
designed to be a compiled language but
in a few minutes we'll see how modern
JavaScript engines can use features of a
compiler to squeeze out additional
performance from the language now
another thing you might hear is that
JavaScript is a dynamically typed
language which tends to be a common
characteristic with high-level
interpreted languages and that just
means that we don't use any explicit
type definitions in vanilla JavaScript
code we can look at this by comparing
some statically typed dart code to some
dynamically typed JavaScript in the dart
code you'll notice that we're annotating
things like integers and strings but the
jas types are unknown or implicit and
that's because the type is associated
with a runtime value and not the actual
variables or functions in your code now
you might also hear that javascript is a
multi-paradigm language the vast
majority of general-purpose programming
languages are multi-paradigm allowing
you to combine styles from declarative
functional approaches or imperative
object-oriented approaches now one of
the weirder things that you'll hear is
that javascript is based on prototypal
inheritance this course will have an
entire video dedicated just to this
topic but the general idea is that
everything in JavaScript is an object
and each object holds a link to its
prototype and this creates a prototype
chain where objects can inherit
behaviors from other objects this can be
a weird thing to get used to if you're
familiar with class-based inheritance
but it's one of the low-level concepts
that makes JavaScript a very flexible
multi-paradigm language now let's take a
second to recap we know that javascript
is a high-level interpreted dynamically
typed multi-paradigm prototype based
language but it's also a single threaded
garbage collected non-blocking language
with an event loop that can be
just-in-time compiled the first set of
definitions are mostly related to how
javascript is laid out in ECMO - 6 - but
it doesn't specify how the
should be implemented how to manage
memory and it doesn't even mention the
event loop in the entire 800 page
document
so that means it's up to the browser
vendors to handle these implementation
details and two of the most popular
implementations are spider monkey from
Mozilla and v8 from Google the way they
work is slightly different but they both
do a thing called just-in-time
compilation in the case of v8 it will
compile all of your JavaScript down to
native machine code before running it as
opposed to interpreting bytecode line by
line like a normal interpreter anyone up
there
fans anybody
[Music]
so these JavaScript engines don't
fundamentally change the way developers
write their code but the JIT compiler
helps improve performance and browsers
and on node but here's the thing
javascript is a single threaded language
so it can only do one computation at a
time
what I want you to do right now in this
browser tab is open up the console with
ctrl shift j and then create a while
loop that never ends you'll notice that
nothing works in this browser tab now if
you try to click on something it will
never capture that event because the
single thread is stuck in that while
loop and it can't move on to the next
event
go into the chrome task manager and you
should see that browser tab using close
to 100% of that CPU cores resources go
ahead and end the process refresh the
tab and then meet me back here to learn
more about why that happened when
executing your JavaScript code to
regions of memory are allocated on the
machine the call stack and the heap the
call stack is designed to be a high
performance continuous region of memory
used to execute your functions when you
call a function it creates a frame and
the call stack that contains a copy of
its local variables if you call a
function within a function it will add
another frame to the stack but if you
return from a function it will pop that
frame off the stack I think the best way
to understand the call stack is to go
through some of your own code
frame-by-frame you can go into these
sources tab in chrome dev tools and
pause the execution of a script and then
you can follow the call stack step by
step if you look down here at the bottom
you can see we're calling this function
called current status when we call that
function it then moves us up to the
function body that first starts with a
console log a console log is a
one-and-done operation so it gets pushed
onto the stack and then executed and
immediately popped off the stack but
then if we go to the next line you can
see it returns a function that also
calls a function for its argument so the
next step is to call that happy function
for the argument and you can see it gets
pushed on to the call stack here and
this happy function has its own local
variable named foo which we can see on
the local scope for this frame in the
call stack and another nice thing is
that you can see that this context for
the function which in this case is the
window so the call stack will push as
many frames as it needs and then start
popping them off as they're executed on
the machine but what happens if we have
a situation where the call stack never
reaches a return statement for example a
recursive function in the stack overflow
function were incrementing a count for
every frame in the call stack now
eventually chrome will throw
a call stack size exceeded error but an
interesting thing to note here is that
each frame in the call stack will
contain a copy of the local count which
we can inspect by traversing through the
call stack but what happens when we run
into something a little more complex
like an object that might be referenced
by multiple function calls outside of
this local context that's when the heap
comes into play it's a mostly
unstructured memory pool where we store
things like objects or primitive values
inside of closures in this code example
we have an object called my counter and
then we're incrementing it with a
function call from there we'll go over
to the memory tab in chrome and take a
heap snapshot and then we can search for
that variable by name and see it in the
heap the special thing about the heap is
that it's garbage collected that means
that v8 or the j/s runtime will try to
clear up free memory when it's no longer
referenced in your code that doesn't
mean you don't need to worry about
memory but it just means that you don't
need to manually allocate and free up
memory like you would in a C language so
now that you know what the call stack
and the heap are all about
we can introduce the event loop now we
already saw how a simple while loop can
entirely break a single-threaded
language so that leads to the question
of how do we handle any kind of
long-running task the answer is the
event loop so let's go ahead and write
our own from scratch in the most basic
sense it's just a while loop that waits
for messages from a queue then processes
their synchronous instructions to
completion in the browser you're already
doing this all the time without even
thinking about it you might set up an
event listener for a button click when
the user clicks that button it sends a
message to the queue and then the
runtime will process whatever JavaScript
you defined as the callback for that
event and that's what makes javascript
non-blocking
because the only thing it ever does is
listen to events and handle callbacks so
it's never actually waiting for the
return value of a function the only
thing it's actually waiting for is the
CPU to process your synchronous code and
for most things that's on a scale of
microseconds now let's imagine the first
iteration of the event loop it will
first handle all of these synchronous
code in the script after it's done
running the synchronous code it checks
if there are any messages or callbacks
in the queue ready to be executed we can
demonstrate this behavior very simply by
adding a set timeout to the top of the
script for 0 seconds now you might
intuitively think that this timeout
should be executed first because it's at
the top of the file and it's a timeout
for 0 seconds but the event loop won't
actually get to it till it's done
running this first iteration of
synchronous code now what makes this so
special is that you can offload
long running jobs two completely
separate thread pools in the browser you
might make an HTTP call that takes a few
seconds to resolve or I know jsut might
need to interact with the file system
but you can do these things without
blocking the main JavaScript thread and
that's almost everything you need to
know about the event loop but javascript
had to go and make things a little more
weird with the introduction of promises
and the micro task queue if we go back
to our script and add a promise resolve
after the set timeout you would think
that we have two asynchronous operations
here with zero delay so the set timeout
would fire first and in the promised
second but there's actually this thing
called the micro task queue for promises
which has priority over the main task
queue used for Dom API s and set
timeouts and things like that that means
the handler for the promise will be
called back first in this case as the
event loop goes through an iteration it
will first handle the synchronous code
then it's going to go to the micro task
queue and handle any of the callbacks
that are ready from your promises and
lastly it will finish up by running the
callbacks that are ready from your set
timeouts or Dom API s and that's how
JavaScript works I guess if all this
sounded overwhelming to you don't worry
too much because you don't really need
to know any of it to start building
stuff with JavaScript in the upcoming
videos in this series we'll look at the
practical applications of JavaScript as
they relate to building real products so
make sure to subscribe and follow along
with the source code on by airship IO
thanks for watching and I will talk to
you soon
[Music]